Jay from Twitter asked, "Alan, how do I
land copywriting clients with no
experience
at all? Thanks for your help." Jay, I'm
going to help you out today and
everybody else who has
jumped into my DMs, replied to my
emails, and asked me this question about
a million freaking times. Even though,
I'll tell you guys, I don't do a ton of
copy work for clients. I write for
myself mostly, and that's what this
channel teaches you. But, at the end of
the day, some of you guys do want to
write for clients, and I do write for
clients on occasions. SO, I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU EXACTLY how to get your first,
second, third, fourth, fifth copywriting
client starting from ground zero, nada,
no experience. Let's make it happen and
jump in. But first,
God bless, that's good. Okay. So,
starting with our first step of getting
your first copywriting client with no
experience. Step number one, can't
believe I have to say this, but I got to
start here. You should study
copywriting, okay? The first thing that
you should be doing is sharpening your
craft, okay? You need to get some books.
But, hold on. The Adweek Copywriting
Handbook, Joe Sugarman, great book. Read
this twice. Boron Letters, okay? Got to
read that. If you haven't read it, read
it twice. Ogilvy on Advertising,
highlight the crap out of this, okay?
Everything they're talking about, read
it twice. Copywriter's Handbook, Robert
Bly, okay? Legend, flip through it,
highlight it, get to know it, study it.
And the reason I say this is because you
need to be good at your craft, okay?
Reading these books is going to give you
the fundamental understanding, and
reading them twice is going to embed it
into your brain to start catching things
in your own copy as you begin writing.
So, first, you need to study. I start
with this first but obvious step because
it weeds out the not serious people.
There are people out here that come out
and think, "Oh, I can just start writing
some copy and make a $10,000 a month and
blah blah blah." That's not how this
works, okay? This is the part where it's
time to get serious. And if you're
serious about your craft, you need to
start reading copy books an hour to two
hours a day, three hours a day, four
hours a day, well, you whatever you
could do. Get off your phone, start
freaking studying. And if you're not
willing to do that, don't be in the copy
game. Go ahead and jump out now. Don't
waste your time. Which leads me to step
number 1.5, okay? So, while you're
studying, I say 1.5 because you should
be doing this alongside your step one.
While you're studying, start building a
network of people that you can have good
relationships with, okay? The top three
places that I recommend you do this are
online social media like X, uh
Instagram, uh TikTok, Medium. You could
do it on any platform. I prefer X. It's
the It's definitely the best place for
relationship building networking. So, I
would get on a social media platform.
The second place you could do this is
like forums. You could do this in a
private forum, right? One that you pay
for to get access to, like a private
Discord community. Or you could do it
like Facebook groups. You could be in a
Facebook group and start building
relationships that way. Subreddits. You
could be in a subreddit. Start building
relationships with people in a community
in the niche that you want to serve,
okay? And lastly, the most obvious one
is in real life relationships, right?
Meeting people for coffee, getting to
know them, their businesses, uh just
cheering them on along the way, building
relationships. You're going to want to
do this now while you're studying
because that's going to lead us to the
next step. And step number two is offer
to write copy for those people for free,
okay? This is the most controversial
thing I'm going to say cuz people are
like, "I don't want to work for free."
Listen, you need to get in the right
mindset. Now is not the time to earn,
it's the time to learn, okay? Alex
Hormozi talks about that all the time,
and it's important for copywriters
because they're so focused on getting
$2,000 retainers, $10,000 retainers that
they don't realize it's not the time for
that, okay? There's no quick scheme
hacks out here. You need to choose your
portfolio, your skill set, and get
sharp. And the best way to do that is
find one of those relationships that you
met on social media, on X, in real life,
at coffee. You say, "Hey, Mr. John, who
has a business about blah blah blah, you
sell bikes, whatever it is. I noticed,
by the way, that you aren't really
taking advantage of email. I would love
to write a couple emails for you, man. A
la carte, you know, pro bono, me, no
problem. I'll write a couple thing. And
if they don't generate more sales for
you, dude, I'm so sorry about that, no
skin off your back. But if they do, I
hope they generate a ton of sales, which
leads me to step number three, prove
that you can get them results, okay? You
write the copy for them, you do free
work for that person, John with the bike
shop, the e-commerce store. You write
it, and you get him results, okay?
That's the point. You're not just
writing emails for him, you're writing
emails that convert to sales, or you're
writing a sales page that converts to
sales, or whatever it is. But you have
to get that person, that free work that
you're doing, get them results. It's not
that you're just writing it and then
moving on and asking for a testimonial,
which I'll get to in a second. But right
now, you're trying to get results,
something that could say, "I wrote for
John's bike shop. And before I was
writing for John's bike shop, he was
making about $500 per email. He'd sell
about a bike per email. Now, when I
write emails for John's bike shop, he
makes $1,500 per email selling three
bikes per email. I tripled John's
sales." That's a case study, right?
That's proof that you're good at what
you do. This is also another barrier to
entry, whether you suck or you don't
suck. I mean, harsh truth, at the end of
the day, this is what separates the boys
from the men, the ladies from the girls,
okay? At this point, if you write copy
and you don't get your client results,
well, guess what? You did it for free,
right? Like, it's not that big a deal,
you tried. But now you could go take
this and learn what am I not doing well?
What am I missing in my study? Am I not
getting enough practice? Am I not
writing enough on my own? Am I not
reading the fundamentals correctly? Am I
not applying those things? And you could
go back and fix your craft while you
have an opportunity to do it with
somebody you know relationally, you
built a relationship with, and there's
no skin off their back, right? It's
free. You're not You're not charging
them, and so you don't have to like
refund them if your stuff sucks.
It You know, you don't burn the
relationship. burn the networking
effect. You're trying your best, and at
the end of the point, we've all screwed
up doing free work for people because we
just did it before we were ready. So,
it's a great opportunity to get good
practice and actually test whether
you're a good copywriter or not. Which
leads me to step number four, ask for
testimonials, okay? Ask for people to
actually give you feedback. Hey man, I
wrote that email for you selling those
bikes. I tripled your sales. Would you
consider writing up a testimonial
talking about that. And John is going to
say, "Hey, I worked with Joe. Joe wrote
this copy for me. It was insane. He
tripled my sales. We sell more bikes
than ever. The copy's really addictive.
Our open rates went up. It was all good
things. I would highly recommend working
for Joe." Okay? And so, now you have
proof from John at the bike shop that
you, Joe, are really good at writing
copy or at least decently good that you
got him enough results that he would be
able to say something nice to you, okay?
Now, you do that three to five times,
okay? You do that three to five times,
and you actually build a portfolio of
testimonials, which
you could put in your Apple notes or
your Notion or whatever. Just collect
them in a note-taking tool of what
people are saying, and then you collect
those things, and now you have a stack
of proof. This could take three months.
It could take six months. It could take
two weeks.
Well, it probably won't take two weeks,
but you get what I'm saying. Like, it
could take as fast as you want. One
great rule is I would recommend a month
of projects, right? So, if you're going
to do five, that's five months worth of
free work that you're going to invest to
say, "Okay, I'm going to take one
project per month. I'm going to do it
for free. I'm going to do uh the copy,
the research, the revisions. I'm going
to go live. I'm going to I'm going to
get them results, and then I'm going to
move on to my next project." And so, you
got five or six months right there of
stacking free work testimonials, really
building your portfolio, which then,
once you have that built, leads us to
the next step. Those people that you
just got testimonials from, you can ask
them for a referral, okay? So, now they
talk to you. They say, "Dude, John, you
did all this for me. So excited. Thanks
so much for the results." And you say,
"Hey, John, while you're at it, thank
you so much for the kind testimonial. Do
you know anybody just like you? I love
to say just like you because it makes
them feel so warm and Oh, just like me?"
Yeah. "Do you know one person just like
you
who would benefit from my copywriting
services?" And John says, "Well, I got
my buddy Jeff, who sells skateboards. I
sell bikes, but he sells skateboards. I
bet he would benefit from your
copywriting service." John, that's super
kind. "Would you be willing to connect
me personally with Jeff?"
And they connect you via email, via
text. They say, "Hey, THIS IS JOE, MY
COPYWRITER GUY. HE DID MY EMAILS. DUDE,
insane results, blah blah blah. You two
want to talk. He can help you sell your
skates and sell your skateboards and all
that stuff." So, he connects you guys.
You do this with the three to five
clients
that you just wrote copy for, okay? And
those three to five clients, by the way,
might actually hire you to continue
writing stuff for them because you're so
good. You're getting them with the
results. They might say, "Hey, man,
instead of me giving you a referral,
would you continue continue to write
emails for me or whatever?" And you And
you give them an offer, right? Which
will be the next step here in a second.
But, at this point, we're now asking for
referrals. So, now you have five people
you wrote copies for them case studies,
and you're asking those five people for
five other people, okay? Now you're in
the game. You are in the game at this
point, which leads me to the next step.
And that is step number six, build an
offer, okay? This is where now you could
start charging people for your
copywriting because you have
testimonials, you have proven results,
you have some experience under your
belt, and you could start charging.
Here's where most people go wrong. They
try and come out the gate and they're
like, "I'm $5,000
for my copywriting skills." And I'm
like, "No, you're not, bro. You're not
$5,000." I mean, unless you absolutely
smash it for John and he's making, you
know, a million dollars in sales because
you're the guy. You're not $5,000, okay?
Craft an offer that's easily digestible.
I can't I It's It's hard to put a range
on this, but you maybe you could start
$200 an email. "Hey, I'll write emails
for you, $200 an email, four emails a
month, that's 800 bucks." Maybe then you
go to $500 an email where you realize
that you're delivering way more value
than that. "Oh, I'm $500 an email. I'm
$1,000 an email." Okay? You start
building whatever your offer is, and
eventually you'll get to "I'm $5,000 a
month plus rev share." Right? Now Now
you're getting fancy once you get your
results, but you can build one offer
that you feel comfortable doing the work
at, and they feel comfortable accepting
the budget, okay? So now you're clawing
your game in to getting paid cuz you got
your testimonials, you got your
referrals, you got some experience, you
got some results, and you can prove that
and start charging people with your
offer. Keep your offer simple, okay?
Keep it very simple. Make it per email
or per result, percentage per result.
Just pick one thing. There's a lot of
resources online that you could kind of
jump into to figure out how to price
your stuff, but right now you just need
to build a simple offer that's
digestible for your client, that's that
you're happy doing the work at, that you
would be stoked at, and then increase
your prices over time. You do five
clients, they're stoked on you, double
your prices. You do five more clients,
triple your prices. And you just keep
climbing up the roads because you keep
stacking that social proof that you are
the jam. Which I technically gave away
our last step. Step number seven,
increase your prices as you build
credibility and proof. Okay, so you do
five clients, double your prices. You do
three clients, four, five more clients.
Okay, triple your prices. You keep
stacking it until you get to a point to
where you've got three to five dream
clients that you're making five to 10k a
month, whatever it is, whatever your
dream amount, whatever you're killing it
on. Okay, you build that over time and
you're going to learn so much building
those relationships with those clients.
Let us recap the step-by-step of this
getting clients from zero experience.
Let's go. Step number one, study, study,
study. You got to study, read those
books, master copywriting and get the
fundamentals down. Step number 1.5 is
build a network of people on forums,
social media, in real life that you can
then connect with later. Step number two
is offer to write copy for them for
free. Okay, this is you building
credibility, testing your skills, and
grabbing those testimonials, which is
step number four, prove that you can get
them results. Okay, prove that you can
get them results. Step number five is
ask for testimonials, three to five
testimonials. Step number six, ask those
same people for referrals. Step number
seven, build an offer and step number
eight, increase your prices as you get
proof. I probably have messed up those
steps and jumbled them up, but you get
what I'm saying. This is how you get
copywriting clients from the get-go, no
experience. Now, disclaimer, this is the
hard route, but this is the real route.
Everybody else will tell you you can
come out of the gate, write copy, and
start landing $5,000 clients. It's not
true. They're lying to you. Okay, this
is This is the actual way that you not
only land clients, but you keep clients.
I cannot tell you how many times
somebody lands a $5,000 client, has no
idea what they're doing, immediately
loses that client, loses credibility
with those people, and then it has an
even harder time climbing back into the
game. Copywriting's not for me, blah
blah blah. This is the real route that
you take. It takes hard work, and if
you're not willing to put in the hard
work, this is not the channel for you,
right? We take intention, hard work, and
we go get it. All right? That's it.
Before we wrap this up, if you liked it,
make sure to like and subscribe to the
channel if you want more content like
this. And lastly, I have a gift for you
if you are a copywriter, which I hope
that you want you watch this whole
video. Uh go ahead, check out the
description below to get a free gift
from me, Copywriting Catalyst, 63 cash
cow tips that you can use immediately to
start making money. Until next time, see
you guys.
That was juicy. That was a juicy one.
All right, I got to put these books up.
You guys better be reading this stuff,
okay? If you're not reading this, I just
don't understand.
I don't understand people that don't
read. But, reading's bad. Have you seen
these gurus online? They're like,
"Reading's a waste of time. Reading's
procrastination." Totally.